brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment I spent the past five days
past week playing role playing games oh
really so it passed my mind when I was
putting my wardrobe together you've been
playing and this morning you were
playing I wanted to get you want to talk
about the actual game that came out not
the demo that's packed with it but you
just come off a stream for Final Fantasy
hope game so please tell me everything
about the demo for Final Fantasy 15 so I
know a lot of people people are
complaining about the dialogue or the
music is like them but I really like it
hmm um I really like that it opens with
I really like that it's about four dudes
who are clearly like really good friends
and it's not like four dudes that have
amassed to this group by traveling
around the world and picking up random
strangers right like I can tell their
friends when this guy this is knocked a
seasoned main character when he is out
of MP and can't attack any more one of
the guys will run over and sort of put
themselves in front of him and shield
him while he's like healing cooling in
the beginning cutscene as they all get
up and they pass him he's still sleeping
they all tap is like tap is G click get
up buddy and they're like throw a lot of
teasing him I really like it I'll
friends because they got together at a
korean like kpop festival okay it's
really weird for me and if you go back
and look at the footage that we are that
we just played today from are now
playing yeah you walk into a gas station
and there's three dudes dressed like
nathan drake like in scarves and
t-shirts okay and then you have your
four guys who are all in like black
leather trench coats and yeah does it's
like slipknot chic or something yeah
it's like super weird well it looks good
like I think the character design looks
great but it doesn't it with like four
dudes going camping Coleman tents got my
lamp and cut la la la salida mother
having said oh my lamb I can't say I got
my lamp the campaign got your lamp the
camping is actually the best part its
form what's the camping Abed is it just
save games or what is it well when you
when you camp you that's when all of
your experience points for the in-game
day aren't tallied up oh and then you
level up and the one guy ignis the guy
with the glasses depending on the
animals that you've killed that day yeah
animals they've killed depending on the
hunting that you've done or the supplies
that you found he cooks and he'll make
different dishes and
dish gives you different status boosts
like one gives you only critical hits
one makes you immune to poison another
one like like bumps up your attack and
defense rate one like like like
completely i think it was like you have
like a solid defense and they're called
like fresh sharp immune like these cute
little names but it's depending on the
food you eat and that's really cool and
if you don't hunt and you keep camping
without hunting you eat toast oh nice
that's pretty good and I guess and
there's no buff on that stuff at all no
you just have some toast those guys
sitting around a campfire toast so I one
of the things like I'm not a big final
fantasy fan I'm playing final fantasy 7
at the moment on my Vita and kind of
like for the first time kind of and I'm
enjoying it but the turn-based stuff is
never really liked or the action
role-playing stuff is never really liked
stroke accorded me what a bit like the
action the actual combat is different
this time right because it seems just
like a normal action game when you see
footage of it yeah so I'm actually going
i'm gonna 15 and type 0 which I just
reviewed review and I yesterday have the
same director so the same guy worked on
both of them and both of them use a
real-time combat type zeros combat is
very good I think 15 s is a lot sharper
although types yours is amazing um
you're literally running around a battle
in in free time and it's it's it's an
action game you get into a get into a
fight as you can see here like you are
in real-time reacting to him there's no
taking turns you can hit you can parry
in this game you can actually throw your
weapon across the battlefield and
teleport to it like strike an enemy and
then bring yourself right up to the
enemy which is cool there you go yeah so
yeah I think a lot of people are
probably going to be buying final
fantasy type-0 in order to play this
yeah but it's time zero worth it as well
from what you played yeah i mean i
really liked it uh we never ever it's
originally a PSP game so this version is
is uh redone it was never released
outside of Japan right no only Japan got
it and it did really well in Japan 2011
or something else and the game I mean
the HD nest don't really doesn't really
extend the whole game like the main
characters are all beautifully rendered
and they look great but then they talk
to an NPC and the NPC is like the flat
PSP like mouth moving like this person
and it's like all right like you didn't
do everyone I just and whatever it's
like the Grim Fandango kind of suffer
feel a little bit as well yeah but it's
a the game is really good the story is
composing and comprehensible so the
story does do these tie together at all
or is this like a the same kind of final
fantasy everything is its own complete
standalone game adventure everything is
its own complete standalone game
adventure although type 0 does use the
whole Lucy fal'cie crystal thing that
final fantasy 13 Dave originally
originally 13 type 0 and then 15 when it
was named vs 13 we're all part of the
same universe but then they sort of
broke them up and did their own thing
and I think 15 is looking better for it
and like every game Sid makes an
appearance what a little bit different
in this one yeah there's a CID um it's a
lady okay she's a mechanic oh I've seen
her in the photo doctor yeah please I
have a lot of problem she looks like a
botanic oh yeah she's all she she is she
like him a comic look at this look at
that wrote her she's just like granted
she's she's nice like she's super cute
and I love the way she spell come on
look what she's wearing come haha yes I
was gonna work on a car yeah but not
dressed like that but look at that card
that's a cool car do you remember the
opening shot of transformers two was it
where are Megan Fox's I'm gonna draped
over the like in the like just oiling
orb like polishing the top oven you're
like for God's sake yeah somebody watch
that movie apparently yeah I'm a little
I mean I like the idea that Sid because
every final fantasy it's so ridiculous
so bad it's not even like oh we're just
like that this is preposterous a lot of
subtle whatever yeah I go for so every
final fantasy has a CID yeah and this is
the first time it's been a girl ok I'm
I'm it's demonic you're like in the
music I think that was a little bit
divisive when we heard it here in the
office well that's the music like so the
music is done by Yoko Shimomura she's a
long time video game composer most
recently she's been working in the
kingdom hearts series and it's sort of
like upbeat whatever um I really like
them I really like the music in this
game it's very uh it's it's very it's
very upbeat it's like it don't like it's
jaunty it's like I don't know it makes
me think of Kingdom Hearts like you walk
into a battle and it's like Oh Disney
battles where you whack each other with
a key yeah and that same sort of bouncy
playfulness is still evident in this 150
cool you still get those you know true
no themes that added a doctor uh no no
not elect all over here in victory theme
how long is the demo actually a 15 so
the demo I was told that if you do
everything and you don't explore like we
took some time to explore today I Peter
did some exploring if you go look at
Peter's footage from pax he actually
tried to steal a car oh I'd like trial
he walked up to the road and was
stopping cars and trying to get them
which is cool um but um it's about three
hours long go do everything in that time
oh and there's like you track of a hema
then we started doing that you go get
money to fix your car you can go to the
chocobo ranch hang out like there's a
lot to do and that is this is I'm sorry
target doesn't bode well do you think
for the full product is it a good taster
considering you played type 0 and that
seems like a pretty solid final fantasy
oh yeah no it's it's one of the better
Final Fantasy titles to come out in
recent years I liked it a lot better
than I liked 1313 was sort of the
hallway ingredient it tips arose mission
structure is like there are rooms
connected to each other and then you can
go do side quests and stuff but it
wasn't so linear like you get to run
around on the overworld and explore and
two side quests and catch oka bows and
breed chocobos you can see Bree choke
about it yeah and it as a demo this
carries over to the main game whenever
like oh right duh I don't know actually
I don't want to say because I don't
think it does I believe that I think
that's what there isn't a save game
stuff but I'm who knows when the main
games coming up yeah for sure as far as
being a good taster I think so cool is
it fair to say that between the sort of
Western release of type 0 and this demo
for Final Fantasy 15 as a longtime fan
of the franchise are we now looking at a
Renaissance final fantasy well fans of
the genre know it to go with that stupid
cliched phrase um are you fighting
episode I love tape Terrell I'm in cryin
courage everyone to go and buy and play
type 0 uh the demo I mean is the only
way can get the demo you basically by
the demo and then you get a copy of
texture with this is crackdown on halo 3
all over again pretty much um but it's
great I there's a lot to look forward to
and that's exciting I like it I think I
think people should be a little less you
know snarking skeptical I think they're
big got a lot today the abbey excellence
and the review on gamespot com of type 0
is going off when that's up already a
lot of our video review is on the
I gave it an eight cool trick again
means it's great awesome x-ray great i
thank you so much for coming on and
thank you all about Final Fantasy